nice run the other day coach vogel said  i put him in the starting lineup because  he had not  played that many minutes and he deserved  it and this is gonna be oh look out  markieff going after boogie  [Applause]  whoa something really excited marquis  morris  and he's still going after him he's not  letting this go  at all  but what he's going to let go is uh some  change  always not always but a lot of time it  happens off the ball is  you can see markief gets called and then  boogie  gives uh markieff a shoulder and a  forearm and  markief really didn't appreciate it at  all so  he retaliates and we'll probably have  them  review this and see if they get both  players with uh technical foul so  cousins was sticking up for jay sean  and then